How many times were you on CppCast? Two times at least. And that was the before Phil Timur era, correct? Yes, that was the good era. Oh my! Oh my! He just blew the game. Phil Timur, I am so, I am so sorry. I am so sorry. I'm sure he just means good because it used to be weekly back then and now it's bi-weekly.
你上过多少次 CppCast？至少两次。那是在 Phil Timur 时代之前，对吧？是的，那是美好的时代。天哪！天哪！他刚才把这事搞砸了。Phil Timur，我太抱歉了。我真的非常抱歉。我相信他只是好意，因为那时候是每周一更，而现在是双周一更。
Is that what you meant? Oh yes, that's what you meant. I must have meant because they invited me. Welcome to ADSP the Podcast, episode 205, recorded on October 11, 2024. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we record live from C++ Under the Sea. In this episode, we interview Phil Nash and Jonathan Mueller. All right, we're here live from the inaugural edition of C++ Under the Sea 2024. I'm here with Bryce, and we are standing across from the nemesis,
你是这个意思吗？哦，是的，你就是这个意思。我一定是那个意思，因为他们邀请了我。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 205 期，录制于 2024 年 10 月 11 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 在“C++ Under the Sea”现场进行录制。在这一集中，我们采访了 Phil Nash 和 Jonathan Mueller。好了，我们现在在 2024 年首届“C++ Under the Sea”大会现场。我和 Bryce 在一起，我们正站在……的对面，
organizer of the conference C++ On C. He's a very lovely fellow, actually. He's a very lovely fellow. But he's got a rival conference now. I'm not sure what he's doing here. I mean, he just finished speaking on a talk he might tell us a little bit about, but my guess is that you're doing recon or some kind of sabotage tactics. I'm going to hand the mic over to Bryce and you can conduct this interview.
C++ On C 大会的组织者。其实他是个非常可爱的人。他是个非常可爱的人。但他现在有一个竞争对手大会。我不确定他在这里做什么。我的意思是，他刚刚做完一场演讲，也许他会告诉我们一些相关内容，但我猜你是在进行侦察或某种破坏战术。我要把麦克风交给 Bryce，你可以进行这次采访。
We are here in lovely Brita. How do we say it? I think it's Brita, but let's ask Phil. So Phil, what's your story? What are you doing here? Well, you've sort of given the game away. This is a bit of a reconnaissance mission, so I need to see what I'm up against. No, no, I'm really supportive of this brand-new conference. It seems to be going really well. Glad to be a part of the first edition.
我们现在在美丽的 Brita。我们怎么读这个词？我想是 Brita，但我们问问 Phil。那么 Phil，你的故事是什么？你在这里做什么？好吧，你已经把底牌亮出来了。这确实有点侦察任务的意思，所以我需要看看我的竞争对手是谁。不，不，我非常支持这个全新的大会。它看起来进行得非常顺利。很高兴能参与第一届大会。
I actually did a workshop yesterday as well. What was your workshop? It was on co-routines. It sold out, so a lot of interest. Yeah, I heard. A sold-out workshop. How many people did you have in your workshop? It was on coroutines. It sold out, so there was a lot of interest. A sold-out workshop. How many people did you have in your workshop? 20. Why do you think people are so interested in learning about coroutines?
我昨天其实也做了一个研讨会。你的研讨会是什么主题？是关于协程的。门票售罄了，所以大家很感兴趣。是的，我听说了。一场门票售罄的研讨会。你的研讨会有多少人参加？是关于协程的。门票售罄了，所以大家很感兴趣。一场门票售罄的研讨会。你的研讨会有多少人参加？20 人。你认为为什么大家对学习协程这么感兴趣？
It's interesting you ask that, because I asked them at the start of the day, what are you actually here for? What are you looking to get out of it? And everyone had a different story. Some of them were just interested in it somebody had specific use cases in mind and others just wanted to see if it was going to help with their particular project and it's one or two people that had some misconceptions we needed to clear up as well so the usual mix i probably could have used that workshop because every time i look at career teams and try to understand how the machinery works, my head explodes.
你问得很有意思，因为我在当天开始时问过他们，你们到底是为什么来这里的？你们想从中得到什么？每个人都有不同的故事。有些人只是感兴趣，有些人有具体的用例，还有些人只是想看看它是否对他们的特定项目有帮助，还有一两个人有一些误解，我们也需要澄清，所以是各种情况的混合。我可能也需要那个研讨会，因为每次我研究协程并试图理解其机制如何工作时，我的头都要炸了。
It's very complex, Phil. It's very complex. Yeah, not a lot of complexity there. And where it is complex, that's to match the complexity of the problem you're trying to solve. The problem is there's just so many moving parts and things you need to understand before you can actually get it to work. So my approach, which is not unique to me, I've seen other people do this as well, is just use the compiler to tell you what the next thing you need to implement is. Even if you don't actually understand what it's for yet, it gets you to that point where you can see something running and then start to page 14 all of the other knowledge.
Phil，这非常复杂。这非常复杂。是的，其实没那么复杂。而在复杂的地方，那是为了匹配你试图解决的问题的复杂性。问题在于有太多的活动部件，在你真正能让它工作之前，你需要理解很多东西。所以我的方法——这对我来说并不独特，我见过其他人也这样做——就是利用编译器来告诉你接下来需要实现什么。即使你还不明白它是为了什么，它也能让你达到能看到代码运行的地步，然后开始逐步消化所有其他知识。
Do you know what symmetric transfer is lewis talks about symmetric transfer a bunch and i i don't really understand it yeah it's actually a fairly simple concept so at the point that you are suspended there's a certain function called await suspend that gets called on your waiter and the return type of await suspend dictates what happens next so if you return void or a boolean with the true value then it says um oh okay we can we can suspend return control back to the caller that's what usually happens that's like the default return force and it says don't suspend it goes back to the to the co-routine but you can also return the co-routine handle of another co-routine and then what it will do is it will just resume that co-routine while this one
你知道什么是对称传输（symmetric transfer）吗？Lewis 经常谈论对称传输，但我真的不太理解。是的，这其实是一个相当简单的概念。在你挂起（suspend）的那一刻，有一个叫 await_suspend 的函数会在你的等待器（awaiter）上被调用，而 await_suspend 的返回类型决定了接下来会发生什么。所以如果你返回 void 或布尔值 true，那么它会说，“哦，好的，我们可以挂起，将控制权返回给调用者”，这通常会发生，就像默认的返回一样。它说不要挂起，它会回到协程，但你也可以返回另一个协程的协程句柄（coroutine handle），然后它会做的是直接恢复那个协程，而当前这个协程
is suspended and very often that co-routine will sort of have a symbiotic relationship and resume the first one again so they go maybe in a cycle there might be a whole chain of them or there may be an external scheduler perhaps in the in the awaiter. However you do it, you can sequence coroutines together without consuming any additional stack space, without the overhead of calling back up the stack to the caller who's going to do it all from there anyway. Coroutines resuming coroutines. Yeah, it's the cycles of the coroutines that always throws me off. It's a little hard to think about. Have you tried using coroutines, Connor?nor i have not i'm waiting for library support i saw i think generator that
处于挂起状态。通常情况下，那个协程会有一种共生关系，并再次恢复第一个协程，所以它们可能会循环往复，可能有一长串的协程，或者在等待器中可能有一个外部调度器。无论你怎么做，你都可以将协程串联起来，而无需消耗任何额外的栈空间，也无需调用回栈顶给调用者的开销。协程恢复协程。是的，协程的循环总是让我感到困惑。这有点难思考。Connor，你试过使用协程吗？我还没有，我在等库支持。我看到生成器（generator）似乎
shipped we have generator and i demonstrated it yesterday yeah i haven't figured it out i've heard library supports coming it's i feel like it's uh i don't think it's actually similar to lambdas because lambdas were understandable even though they were only half-baked in 11 and then once we got to 14, it was fully... I feel like in this case, coroutines are this complicated language feature that honestly we aren't expecting most people to use as a language feature.
发布了，我们有生成器，我昨天演示了它。是的，我还没搞明白。我听说库支持快来了。我觉得它……我不认为它实际上类似于 lambda，因为 lambda 是可以理解的，即使它们在 C++11 中只是半成品，一旦到了 C++14，它就完全……我觉得在这种情况下，协程是一个复杂的语言特性，老实说，我们并不指望大多数人将其作为语言特性来使用。
We're going to have library implementers that are going to be shipping library features and then it's going to be much easier for folks to consume coroutine-esque things that are built on top of it. That's what I'm waiting for. What are the other library pieces that you think are missing? So generator is a particular type of coroutine that has co-yield in it, usually in a loop.
我们将会有库实现者发布库功能，然后人们消费构建在它之上的协程类事物会容易得多。这就是我在等待的。你认为还缺少哪些库组件？所以生成器是一种特殊的协程，通常在循环中包含 co_yield。
And that generalizes really easily. And even that was actually quite complex to standardize for reasons. But the other type of coroutine we usually call call a task although it's a bit more general than that it's not just called task the trouble is there's no single semantic for what a task actually is so sometimes it's just going to be something you can suspend and resume at different points maybe cooperatively multi-task with other tasks or it could be that waiting for a resource to load over the network or from a file system or user input whatever it's awaiting on you can even use co routines to await on stood
这很容易泛化。即使是这一点，由于种种原因，标准化起来也相当复杂。但我们通常称之为“任务”（task）的另一种协程，尽管它比那更通用，不仅仅叫任务。问题在于对于什么是任务并没有单一的语义，所以有时它只是你可以挂起并在不同点恢复的东西，也许与其他任务协作式多任务处理，或者它可能是等待资源通过网络或文件系统或用户输入加载，无论它在等待什么，你甚至可以使用协程来等待 std::
optional or stood expected and use it as a way to do magnetic error handling because co routines themselves actually model monads so monads are effectively interchangeable in that sense so lots of different uses that's why it's really hard to to really pin down a specific implementation for the standard we're going to need at least so this uh this uh task thing which has also been called stood lazy at some points so what is it is it an awaitable? Is it a you know, a coroutine itself? Like what sort of thing is it? How would somebody use this thing? Like what would be a use case for it?
optional 或 std::expected，并将其作为一种进行单子（monadic）错误处理的方式，因为协程本身实际上模拟了单子，所以单子在某种意义上是可互换的。所以有很多不同的用途，这就是为什么很难真正确定标准的具体实现。我们需要至少……这个“任务”东西，有时也被称为 std::lazy。那么它是什么？它是一个可等待对象（awaitable）吗？它本身是一个协程吗？它是什么样的东西？有人会如何使用它？比如它的用例是什么？
Yeah, this is where getting into what it actually is starts to reveal some of that complexity under the hood. Wait, so we want this thing, but we don't really know what this thing is? Once we have it, once we have standard versions as long as it matches the semantics you want you won't have to worry about what's under the hood
是的，这就是深入了解它到底是什么开始揭示底层一些复杂性的地方。等等，所以我们想要这个东西，但我们并不真正知道它是什么？一旦我们有了它，一旦我们有了标准版本，只要它符合你想要的语义，你就不必再担心底层是什么了。
anymore but to understand what it's doing right now you do have to so the task itself is something you write and it's really just your interface to the coroutine so the low level interface is the coroutine handle and you also get this thing called the promise type that sort of serves two roles. So the coroutine machinery calls into that, but you can also store things in there and get things out again. So it's like where you store things shuffling to and from a coroutine. But rather than expose all that low-level complexity to the end user, you wrap it all up in this task type,
但要理解它现在在做什么，你确实需要。所以任务本身是你编写的东西，它实际上只是你与协程的接口。底层接口是协程句柄，你还会得到一个叫“承诺类型”（promise type）的东西，它扮演了两个角色。协程机制会调用它，但你也可以在里面存储东西并再次取出。所以它就像是你存储在协程之间来回传递数据的地方。但与其向最终用户暴露所有这些底层复杂性，你将它全部封装在这个任务类型中，
and that gives you a nice sort of semantic-driven interface that matches what you want to do. So it is an abstraction around the coroutine handle. The coroutine handle and the promise type. And the promise type. I think the best solution here is next time you see Phil's name or even another individual giving a training session or a workshop at a conference, you just got to go sign up,
这为你提供了一个很好的、语义驱动的接口，符合你想要做的事情。所以它是围绕协程句柄的一个抽象。协程句柄和承诺类型。还有承诺类型。我认为最好的解决方案是，下次你看到 Phil 的名字，或者其他人在大会上进行培训或研讨会时，你只需要去报名，
go to the conference. Speaking of which, you are the organizer, mentioned of the Arch Nemesis. I mean, I'm not sure if the conferences are rivals, but at least in ADSP lore, they will be now. Can we even mention the name of his conference or will they kick us out of this one? Oh, no, we definitely can do whatever we want. It's our podcast. So C++ on C, which is actually the last time I believe we interviewed you, was live at that conference. Since then, you've also launched two more conferences, I believe. C++ Online.
去参加大会。说到这个，你是组织者，提到了死对头。我的意思是，我不确定这些大会是否是竞争对手，但至少在 ADSP 的传说中，它们现在是了。我们甚至可以提到他大会的名字吗？还是他们会把我们赶出这个大会？哦，不，我们绝对可以做任何我们想做的事。这是我们的播客。所以 C++ on C，我相信上次我们采访你时，就是在那个大会现场。从那时起，我相信你又发起了两个大会。C++ Online。
So C++ on C was in Folkestone, still is in Folkestone. It just finished happening, I believe, in June. And you also have now C++ Online, which is an online conference. And I actually don't know what the name of the Swift conference is. I'm going to guess it's Swift something. Yes, so I launched Swift something this year. Why a Swift conference? Well, first of all, it's SwiftCraft is the name.
所以 C++ on C 在 Folkestone，现在仍然在 Folkestone。我相信它刚刚在六月结束。你现在还有 C++ Online，这是一个在线大会。我其实不知道 Swift 大会的名字。我猜是 Swift 什么的。是的，我今年发起了 SwiftCraft。为什么是 Swift 大会？好吧，首先，它的名字叫 SwiftCraft。
And I did a lot of Swift some years ago now. Well, I started with Objective-C writing. My sympathies. Objective-C is very misunderstood. It's got some good stuff. But most of that good stuff actually transferred to Swift, so that's good.
而且我几年前做了很多 Swift 开发。好吧，我开始是用 Objective-C 编写的。我深表同情。Objective-C 被严重误解了。它有一些好东西。但大部分好东西实际上转移到了 Swift，所以这很好。
Not all of it. We're still missing some stuff. But no, Swift was a great language when it came out. Those of us sort of watching for it couldn't believe how good it was compared to what we had before. So I really got into it in the early days maybe a little bit too much got a bit burnt by the um the bugs in the
并非全部。我们仍然缺少一些东西。但不，Swift 在刚出来时是一门很棒的语言。我们这些关注它的人简直不敢相信它比我们以前拥有的东西好多少。所以我很早就投入其中，也许投入得有点太多了，被……中的 bug 烧伤了。
early support and lack of features uh and then stopped doing that as a side project for a while so i drifted away from it i'm trying to get back into it but i built up connections in the swift community i know lots of people there uh there's some There's a great community as well. And there's some great talks in that community. So I just wanted to bring that back to the Southeast UK area, where there used to be an iOS conference that went away pre-pandemic. And there seems to be a bit of a gap in the market. I was, Phil and I were talking last night, and I've got this project that I want to start, and I'd like to use Tristan's Flux library, but my question was, you know, what should I do? Because I'm dearly missing pattern matching, proper language, some type.
早期支持和缺乏功能……然后有一段时间停止将其作为副业。所以我逐渐远离了它，我正试图重新开始，但我已经在 Swift 社区建立了联系，我认识那里很多人……那里也有一个很棒的社区。那个社区里有一些很棒的演讲。所以我只是想把它带回英国东南部地区，那里曾经有一个 iOS 大会，但在疫情前消失了。市场似乎有一点空白。Phil 和我昨晚在谈话，我有一个想开始的项目，我想使用 Tristan 的 Flux 库，但我的问题是，我该怎么办？因为我非常怀念模式匹配、合适的语言、和代数数据类型。
Stidvarian doesn't cut it. And I asked, you know, what should I do if I want to stay in C++? And what did you tell me, Phil? I said, you know, what should I do if I want to stay in C++? And what did you tell me, Phil? I said, use Swift. And I said, the question was about C++. And Phil said, no, yes, my answer is use Swift. And there you go, folks. He's the runner of two C++.
std::variant 根本不够用。我问，如果我想留在 C++ 中，我该怎么办？Phil，你告诉了我什么？我说，如果我想留在 C++ 中，我该怎么办？Phil，你告诉了我什么？我说，用 Swift。我说，问题是关于 C++ 的。Phil 说，不，是的，我的回答是使用 Swift。好了，各位，这就是答案。他是两个 C++ 大会的组织者。
And we failed to mention the current co-host of CppCast and the former co-host of, like, multiple other C++ podcasts. Link in the show notes if you want to go listen to the backlog. To wrap this up, what can you tell us? I know you said things haven't launched, but this is going to be released in probably two weeks. So today is October 10th, 17th, 24th. So probably in the last week of October. Just keep that in mind based on when this is going to come out. So what was the question again? So what can you tell us about C++ Online? Because I know that it was in February last year,
我们忘了提到 CppCast 的现任联合主持人，以及其他多个 C++ 播客的前联合主持人。如果你想去听往期节目，节目说明中有链接。总结一下，你能告诉我们什么？我知道你说有些东西还没发布，但这大概会在两周后发布。所以今天是 10 月 10 日、17 日、24 日。所以大概在 10 月的最后一周。考虑到这期节目发布的时间，请记住这一点。那么问题又是什么？你能告诉我们关于 C++ Online 的什么信息？因为我知道它去年是在二月，
is call for papers, registration. What is the state of conferences that you will be organizing in 2025 for folks listening to this in October slash November of 2024? Right. Yeah. So C++ Online, by the time you hear this, call for speakers should be open. Technically, it's actually online right now. If you go to speak.cpponline.uk, you can actually register and submit your proposals now. With a secret link. Yeah, with a secret link. There you go. Same as last year, so not that secret. But it just hasn't been formally announced yet because we just haven't got around to it
是征稿、注册。对于在 2024 年 10 月/11 月收听此节目的听众来说，你将在 2025 年组织的大会处于什么状态？对。是的。所以 C++ Online，当你听到这个的时候，演讲者征集应该已经开放了。技术上讲，它现在已经在网上了。如果你访问 speak.cpponline.uk，你现在就可以注册并提交你的提案。用一个秘密链接。是的，用一个秘密链接。就是这样。和去年一样，所以没那么秘密。但它还没有正式宣布，因为我们还没来得及处理，
because I've been preparing for this workshop and this conference. So next week, that should go out. That will be all online. It should be running the last week of February, if I remember that right off the top of my head. C++ on C will open a bit later. Currently, as we speak here, October 10th, ACCU corporate speakers is also... Oh, yeah, I just saw here, October 10th, ACCU called for speakers.
因为我一直在准备这个研讨会和这个大会。所以下周，它应该会发布。那将全部在线进行。如果我没记错的话，它应该在二月的最后一周举行。C++ on C 会晚一点开放。正如我们现在所说，10 月 10 日，ACCU 征稿也……哦，是的，我刚才看到了，10 月 10 日，ACCU 征稿。
Oh, yeah, I just saw that, yeah. A little early this year, I think. So we've opened it earlier than last year, but that was mostly because last year we opened a bit late. Ah, I understand, I understand. Now, is CPP on C this year not going to be over
哦，是的，我看到了，是的。今年早了一点，我想。所以我们比去年开放得更早，但这主要是因为去年我们开放得有点晚。啊，我明白了，我明白了。那么，今年的 CPP on C 不会是在
a major U.S. holiday weekend? No, it's the last week in June. Okay, the last week in June. Was it, what do you call that, America Day? It was July 4th, and flights were too expensive for Bryce, which is saying something. Yeah, I mean, how was 2024 CBP on Sea? Was Sean there? Because I remember we had a great time interviewing Sean.
美国的一个重大节假日周末吧？不，是在六月的最后一周。好的，六月的最后一周。那是……你叫它什么，美国国庆日？那是 7 月 4 日，机票对 Bryce 来说太贵了，这说明了什么。是的，我的意思是，2024 年的 C++ on Sea 怎么样？Sean 在吗？因为我记得我们采访 Sean 时玩得很开心。
Still one of the highlights of the podcast. It is probably my favorite C++ conference right now. Whoa, look at that. Look at that. That is breaking news, folks. I didn't even know that. Yeah, well, I guess my vote. No, Sean wasn't there this year.
这仍然是该播客的亮点之一。它可能是目前我最喜欢的 C++ 大会。哇，看那个。看那个。各位，这是突发新闻。我甚至都不知道。是的，好吧，我想这是我的投票。不，Sean 今年没去。
Maybe he'll be there next year. Well, maybe we'll interview you again at cpp on c yeah we'll have to we'll have to do a reunion at some point yeah get sean the three of us back together we'll have uh wine like we did last time wait there was wine do you remember we got kicked when we had dinner we got kicked out of the place because they were they were wrapping up and uh and like we were taking our wine oh my god i do remember that i tweeted i had a uh reasonable amount of wine and then sean took the wine bottle and was like no you got to have some more there and uh still one of the highlights of uh my professional it was very professional sean parent trying to get each other was one of the highlights of your
也许他明年会去。好吧，也许我们会在 C++ on C 再次采访你。是的，我们得在某个时候搞个重聚。是的，把 Sean 和我们三个聚在一起。我们会像上次那样喝红酒。等等，有红酒吗？你记得吗？我们吃晚饭时被赶出来了，因为他们要打烊了，而我们还在喝红酒。天哪，我记得那个。我发推文说我喝了适量的红酒，然后 Sean 拿过红酒瓶说，不，你得再喝点。那仍然是我职业生涯的亮点之一。Sean Parent 试图……是我们职业生涯的亮点之一。
career it was it was a great. It was a great night. It was a great night. And we silently launched without letting people know. Was it Val? Now Hilo? Something. Yeah, I think so. Yeah.
那是一个很棒的夜晚。那是一个很棒的夜晚。我们悄悄地发布了，没有让人们知道。是 Val 吗？现在是 Hilo？什么的。是的，我想是这样。是的。
There are C++ talks as well. There are also C++ talks. There's very good content at the conference, which is why I like it. The hallway track is always the best track, though, folks. Especially the more and more conferences you go to, it becomes the thing that is most unique. Because at some point, you've seen the talk about X, the talk about Y. If it's your first conference, you'll be thrilled by the talks. But then after your fifth, sixth conference, it's the hallway track that's always unique to each conference.
也有 C++ 演讲。也有 C++ 演讲。大会的内容非常好，这就是我喜欢它的原因。不过，走廊交流（hallway track）永远是最好的环节，各位。特别是你参加的大会越多，它就越成为最独特的东西。因为在某种程度上，你已经看过关于 X 的演讲，关于 Y 的演讲。如果是你的第一次大会，你会对演讲感到兴奋。但到了第五、第六次大会，走廊交流才是每个大会独一无二的地方。
You should definitely go to more C++ conferences, especially C++ on C. And Phil only pays us a very reasonable commission to say all these nice things about his conference. Oh, you don't have to say that. All right, we've got 10 minutes. We've got 10 minutes.
你绝对应该参加更多的 C++ 大会，尤其是 C++ on C。Phil 只付给我们非常合理的佣金来为他的大会说这些好话。哦，你不必那样说。好了，我们还有 10 分钟。我们还有 10 分钟。
We've got to go. So, yeah, we'll see you around, Phil. Thanks for being interviewed. And we will either go find Kuhn now or FlorisBob.ist bob but yeah we'll see you around phil we're here with think cell employee okay jonathan in front of the think cell booth yeah how's it going it's going great have you seen any talks or have you been just busy no i've seen the keynote and then I spent the second time slot writing a paper
我们得走了。所以，是的，Phil，回头见。谢谢你接受采访。我们现在要么去找 Kuhn，要么去找 FlorisBob。Bob，但是的，Phil，回头见。我们现在和 ThinkCell 的员工在一起，好的，Jonathan 在 ThinkCell 展位前。是的，进展如何？进展很棒。你看过什么演讲吗？还是你一直很忙？不，我看了主题演讲，然后我把第二个时间段花在写论文上了，
since I was told the deadline is coming up. Wow, that's efficient use of your time. The deadline is in fact coming up. What was your paper? So I'm working on a paper to decouple the meta header from reflection from the rest of the standard library to make it more vitally used in contexts where people don't like the standard library.
因为有人告诉我截止日期快到了。哇，真是高效利用时间。截止日期确实快到了。你的论文是什么？我正在写一篇论文，旨在将反射的元头文件（meta header）与标准库的其余部分解耦，使其在人们不喜欢标准库的环境中得到更广泛的使用。
I'm just going to give it a shot. how would that what what does that even mean decouple it from the standard library also should we back up for two seconds because technically you do get mentioned in one of the guest lists i think on the c++ on c interview chaotic thing we did like a year and a half ago but that like like, I think you had all of half of a sentence, but I thought it was worth putting you like in the guest interview. We asked you a question and you had like a four word answer. But other than that, I don't think we've actually ever interviewed you. So introduce yourself.
我打算试一试。那……那意味着什么？把它从标准库中解耦？还有，我们应该倒退两秒钟吗？因为从技术上讲，你确实出现在嘉宾名单中，我想是在我们一年半前做的那个混乱的 C++ on C 采访中。但我觉得，我想你只说了半句话，但我认为值得把你列入嘉宾采访。我们问了你一个问题，你只回答了四个字。但除此之外，我想我们从未真正采访过你。所以介绍一下你自己。
Then we'll go back to this meta decoupling paper writing thing. Are we going to cut that or is this just an Out of Order podcast? Out of Order podcast, okay. I'm Jonathan. You know me from the four words I said on the previous episode on the C++NC podcast. It must have been very important. Now I work at ThinkCell. I'm a software engineer.
然后我们再回到这个元解耦论文写作的事情。我们要剪掉那段吗？还是这是一个乱序播客？乱序播客，好的。我是 Jonathan。你们从我在 C++ on C 播客上一期说的四个字中认识我。那一定非常重要。现在我在 ThinkCell 工作。我是一名软件工程师。
You know me from my blog, funathon.net or something. I'm assuming. Does your audience know me? Yes, I think 80% of the audience does know you because you've also been a one-time, two-time guest on CBBCast, three-time. How many times were you on CBBCast? Two times at least. And that was the before Phil Timur era, correct?
你们从我的博客 funathon.net 或类似的地方认识我。我假设。你的听众认识我吗？是的，我想 80% 的听众都认识你，因为你也曾是一次、两次、三次做客 CppCast。你上过多少次 CppCast？至少两次。那是在 Phil Timur 时代之前，对吧？
Yes, that was the good era. Oh, my! Oh, my! He just blew the game. Phil Timur, I am so sorryer I am so sorry I am so sorry I'm sure he just means good because it used to be weekly back then And now it's bi-weekly
是的，那是美好的时代。天哪！天哪！他刚才把这事搞砸了。Phil Timur，我太抱歉了。我真的非常抱歉。我相信他只是好意，因为那时候是每周一更，而现在是双周一更。
Is that what you meant? Oh yes, that's what you meant I must have meant because they invited me You're not going to get invited back A fourth time I don't think So what does ThinkCell do? You were explaining this to me at dinner last night.
你是这个意思吗？哦，是的，你就是这个意思。我一定是那个意思，因为他们邀请了我。你不会再被邀请第四次了。我不这么认为。那么 ThinkCell 是做什么的？你昨晚在晚餐时向我解释过。
You did a pretty good job. When are we supposed to go back to the meta? Okay, now we're doing just out-of-order. It's his introduction, though, right? He said he works at ThinkCell. People don't know what that is. Yeah, we sell a plugin for PowerPoint that makes it easier to create slides and charts.
你做得很好。我们什么时候该回到元（meta）的话题？好的，现在我们只是乱序。不过这是他的介绍，对吧？他说他在 ThinkCell 工作。人们不知道那是什么。是的，我们销售一个 PowerPoint 插件，使创建幻灯片和图表更容易。
We're the standard for the consultants and everybody who makes a living doing PowerPoint slides because it's just so much faster to create slides with a product. And I think I've said slides enough to earn my salary for this month. You are here with the marketing and recruiting part of your company. Alright, so back to your paper.
我们是顾问和所有靠做 PowerPoint 幻灯片为生的人的标准，因为用这个产品创建幻灯片要快得多。我想我已经说了足够多的“幻灯片”来赚取我这个月的工资了。你在这里代表你们公司的市场和招聘部门。好了，回到你的论文。
The C++ standard doesn't say anything about the structure of the standard library. That's left up to the implementation. What do you mean by decoupling meta from the rest of the standard library. That's left up to the implementation. What do you mean by decoupling meta from the rest of the library? Do you mean like removing dependencies? Yes, it's about dependencies. So like meta is one of those headers that you cannot implement yourself.
C++ 标准对标准库的结构只字未提。这留给了实现者。你所说的将元（meta）与标准库的其余部分解耦是什么意思？这留给了实现者。你所说的将元与库的其余部分解耦是什么意思？你是说像移除依赖项吗？是的，是关于依赖项。所以像 meta 是那些你无法自己实现的头文件之一。
You need like compiler built-ins for that. And there are like many people that don't use the standard library yet still want to use reflection. For example, the function like members of or whatever is the current name with all the private shenanigans going on i haven't kept up with that returns a vector of meta info objects it does it at compile time so like you don't have to pay any dynamic memory allocation but you still pull in the entire include of the vector and require like an implementation of vector even at compile time and there's also some concerns by like implementers that it's like, because essentially the thing
你需要编译器内置函数来实现它。有很多不使用标准库但仍然想使用反射的人。例如，像 members_of 这样的函数，或者无论当前名字是什么，因为所有私有的混乱情况，我没跟上，它返回一个 meta info 对象的向量。它在编译时完成，所以你不需要支付任何动态内存分配，但你仍然引入了整个 vector 的头文件，甚至在编译时也需要 vector 的实现。而且实现者也有一些担忧，因为本质上这个东西
reps like a compiler built in that just gives you like a pointer and a size. And then you have to somehow turn that into a vector. And this is quite expensive. The advantage is that you then can call pushback on it. But in the vast majority of cases, you just need it as a range and iterate over it. So it doesn't really have to be a vector. It can be like an implementation defined type. Okay, that's fine.
代表了一个编译器内置函数，它只给你一个指针和一个大小。然后你必须以某种方式将其转换为向量。这相当昂贵。优点是你可以在它上面调用 push_back。但在绝大多数情况下，你只需要把它当作一个范围（range）并遍历它。所以它不一定非得是向量。它可以是某种实现定义的类型。好的，没问题。
So you essentially, you want it to be more of a freestanding header? I want it to be more freestanding. Technically vector at compile time is freestanding, but it's still a thing that people have to do. The more controversial parts are stuff like whether name of should return a string view or a char pointer and things like that. It should review a string view or a char pointer?
所以你本质上是希望它更像一个独立（freestanding）的头文件？我希望它更独立。从技术上讲，编译时的 vector 是独立的，但这仍然是人们必须做的事情。更有争议的部分是像 name_of 应该返回 string_view 还是 char 指针之类的问题。它应该返回 string_view 还是 char 指针？
Right now it returns a string view, and I'm proposing that it returns a char pointer and just having that parallel and see what happens. I mean, I think we do have some other interfaces lower. Like, what does source location return? Yeah, exactly. Source location returns the const char pointer. I don't know what contract does.
现在它返回 string_view，我提议它返回 char 指针，并让它们并行存在，看看会发生什么。我的意思是，我认为我们确实有其他更底层的接口。比如，source_location 返回什么？是的，没错。Source_location 返回 const char 指针。我不知道 contract 返回什么。
I don't. That's not real yet. So what was the reason that source location is fairly new? What was the reason that it returns const char? I'm assuming it's to avoid pulling in string view. Yeah, I'm pretty sure that that's right. Yeah, and I think it may have also been something about the implementation concerns too. And it was considered fine because it's just like a string constant,
我不知道。那还没实现。那么 source_location 相当新，原因是什么？它返回 const char 的原因是什么？我假设是为了避免引入 string_view。是的，我很确定那是对的。是的，我想这可能也与实现方面的担忧有关。而且这被认为是没问题的，因为它就像一个字符串常量，
like a compile time constant. It's always what it is. Yeah, I don't know. You might win that particular set of debates. Yeah, we have to see. Like, you can, like, some of the APS, like, they're adding, like, some of the APS they keep adding are, like, really tricky, and they pull in, like, a whole bunch of ranges machinery.
就像一个编译时常量。它永远是它本来的样子。是的，我不知道。你可能会赢得那场特定的辩论。是的，我们得看看。有些 API，它们不断添加的 API 真的很棘手，它们引入了一大堆 ranges 机制。
And changing that in a way without having to pull in the ranges machinery is a bit tricky. And if you're pulling in ranges, then what's the point of a Springview anyway? So there is some... As I said, I started writing this paper an hour ago. Will there be a paper number by October 24th for us to include in the show notes?
在不引入 ranges 机制的情况下改变这一点有点棘手。如果你引入了 ranges，那么 string_view 还有什么意义呢？所以有一些……正如我所说，我一小时前才开始写这篇论文。到 10 月 24 日会有论文编号供我们放入节目说明吗？
There probably already is a paper number. There already is a paper number. If we walk a bit over there, I can... Also, do we win any of this free stuff? You know, I already have so many ThinkCell socks. I'm just not taking any more ThinkCell socks. We don't just get them?
可能已经有论文编号了。已经有论文编号了。如果我们走过去一点，我可以……另外，我们能得到任何免费的东西吗？你知道，我已经有太多 ThinkCell 的袜子了。我只是不再拿 ThinkCell 的袜子了。我们不是直接就能拿到吗？
I'm good. I've already got them. The paper number is... is... 4329. 4329, folks. And if you don't know the trick, it's wg21.link slash p and then the paper number. Or is it p slash the paper number? I remember before there were p numbers. I remember 4,000 papers ago. It's news to me that Bryce was born before P numbers. All right, we've got three minutes until the next talk.
我够了。我已经有了。论文编号是……是……4329。4329，各位。如果你不知道这个技巧，它是 wg21.link/p 然后是论文编号。还是 p/论文编号？我记得在有 p 编号之前。我记得 4000 篇论文之前。Bryce 出生在 P 编号之前，这对我来说是新闻。好了，距离下一次演讲还有三分钟。
It's lunchtime, folks, in case we haven't mentioned. We were actually trying to get Jason Turner, the first keynote speaker of the day, because he is leaving quickly after the conference ends, the final keynote. So we only have the break at 3 o'clock, I believe, till 3.30 local time to hunt him down. Thank you so much, Jonathan, for being on the podcast for more than just a single sentence. Any final words to share with our C++ slash non-C++ listeners? The mic is yours. I'm kind of regretting this because I now have to finish writing the paper. Well, you already had the numbers.
各位，现在是午餐时间，如果我们还没提到的话。我们其实一直在试图找 Jason Turner，当天的第一位主题演讲者，因为他在大会结束后的最后一场主题演讲后很快就会离开。所以我想我们只有下午 3 点到 3 点 30 分（当地时间）的休息时间来找到他。非常感谢 Jonathan 参加播客，不仅仅是说了一句话。有什么最后的话想对我们的 C++ / 非 C++ 听众分享吗？麦克风交给你。我有点后悔了，因为我现在必须完成论文的写作。好吧，你已经有了编号。
So whether you got into this mailing, you would have got into a mailing at some point. And no, not if you never press submit. I've got a couple of numbers. Every committee member has a collection of paper numbers that they haven't submitted. And you know it, too, because every now and, like, a P0700 gets published, and it's, like, next to, like, all the 4,000 papers. And you're like, what happened here? And it's like, oh, well, somebody had an idea back in 2018,
所以无论你是否进入了这个邮件列表，你迟早都会进入的。不，如果你从不点击提交，就不会。我有几个编号。每个委员会成员都有一堆他们还没提交的论文编号。你也知道，因为每隔一段时间，比如 P0700 就会发布，它就像在所有 4000 篇论文旁边，你会想，这里发生了什么？就像，哦，好吧，有人在 2018 年有个想法，
and they just never got around to it. Yeah. I actually, when I, like, opened the Git repository with my papers, I saw a bunch of, like, completely unstaged papers that I started writing, like, over a year ago, and I have absolutely no memory of me doing that. I also save some good paper numbers so I got a couple
他们只是没来得及处理。是的。我其实在打开带有我论文的 Git 仓库时，看到了一堆完全未暂存的论文，是我一年多前开始写的，我完全不记得我做过那件事。我也保存了一些好的论文编号，所以我有一些
good ones and like I just, my old paper numbers that I reserved I've just like, they're just now a reserve like in case I need like to publish some really impactful paper so people will have a good number. And sometimes I email the admin chairs and I'm like hey can you give me this paper number so I got some of the good number. And sometimes I email the admin chairs. I'm like, hey, can you give me this paper number?
好的编号，我预留的旧论文编号……它们现在只是预留着，以防我需要发布一些非常有影响力的论文，这样人们就会有一个好的编号。有时我会给管理主席发邮件，说嘿，你能给我这个论文编号吗？所以我得到了一些好的编号。有时我会给管理主席发邮件。我说，嘿，你能给我这个论文编号吗？
So I got some of the good ones. All right, folks. You heard it here. The broken process of paper number, you know. I don't know what to say. We'll see you around at the conference. Hopefully, you'll be at the final keynote at least, I imagine. Yeah?
所以我得到了一些好的编号。好了，各位。你们在这里听到了。论文编号的破碎流程，你知道。我不知道该说什么。我们在大会上见。希望你至少会参加最后的主题演讲，我想。是吗？
Yeah, I don't plan on leaving until tomorrow. Okay. We'll see you around then I can pretend to be Jason Turner if you can't find him I would like to hear your Jason Turner impression
是的，我不打算在明天之前离开。好的。那我们回头见，如果你找不到 Jason Turner，我可以假装成他。我很想听听你的 Jason Turner 模仿秀。
I'm getting my life choices be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast dot com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode
我正在选择我的人生道路。请务必在你的播客应用中或访问 ADSPthepodcast.com 查看这些节目说明，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接。
as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts comments and questions thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那不是标语。我们的标语是“充满信息点缀的混乱”。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。